yeah I think part of this is people
don't understand how the system works
obviously but what you're talking about
here is in this deflationary environment
there's two things that I think are
really important so the first is this
idea that right now we ask American
citizens and citizens around the world
be an expert of what you do for a living
so whether you're a teacher
fireman investor you know whatever it is
you do for a professional living you've
got to be a professional right you've
got to be one of the best then we also
say by the way you can't just make money
and hold on to that money because
ultimately that money will lose value
over time we're going to incentivize you
to either spend it or invest it so you
can spend it right you can be consumer
and consume more or we then say to you
you either have to become a professional
investor as well or you're gonna have to
pay somebody who is a professional to
invest the money for you and so what
ends up occurring here is the idea of
saving actually isn't nearly as valuable
as it should be right you're basically
saving something that's just leaking it
through the holes in a bucket to some
degree and and so when you move to a
deflationary environment what you can
actually say to somebody is the money
that you are paid if you save it over
time you will become wealthier you will
be rewarded for having a low time
preference and for saving rather than be
incentivized to either become a
professional investor or pay somebody to
invest your capital and I think that
just that alone changes the way that
wealth is distributed throughout the
world simply by taking the bottom 50
percent and structurally putting them at
an advantage rather than a disadvantage
yeah exactly and and capitalism works
perfectly in that system the the so
exactly so today instead of thinking it
as money think about it is I put a pizza
in the bank right so I can heat and I go
back to the inn and it's in four slices
and I can eat for four four days and
then I go back to the bank and it's in
six slices and I can't
I'm still hungry right I got I got my I
got my pizza but it doesn't feed me at
this a bit of the same I got what they
they said that they divided it and it
doesn't feed me the same and so if you
think about what's happening in our
economies right that's what's happening
and in our economies and so no wonder
people are rising up no wonder there no
wonder the bottom half is looking at
things we didn't see we haven't seen
since the thirties right 20s and 30 the
socialism and that how rampant that hold
that because the system right now
doesn't work yeah let's talk about the
transition period between the inflation
to deflation right so we cannot
understand how the existing system works
we understand here's a world that could
work better the transition is I think
the part that scares the [ __ ] out of
most people right they say yeah and so
what in your opinion like how does that
transition most likely happen and then
what is the good parts of the transition
and then what are the they're scary bad
parts of it so a cleansing of the system
is required right that cleansing of the
system is going to happen one way or
they up that's if we keep doing what
we're doing
currencies are going to break because
now it's just game theory and global
currencies and everybody's printing more
so if every currency is printing more
you've ruined the trust of what the
fundamental unit of value is and and if
you can't trust that trade trade
collapses and and and so and that's not
that's this that's a huge problem but
that's a small problem
the bigger problem of that is
politicians get elected with that and
and blame other people for creating the
problem which creates revolution and war
right you can see that in your political
in the US political cycle today you can
see that around the world and it's all
caused from the same thing it's it's
people want to believe somebody and
they'll believe anybody it's it's easier
to say it's his fault rather than take
to say it's a structural
it's easier to play them something it's
easier to blame China it's easier to
blame somebody else and then as that
starts to happen and you you you have
you have to create a bigger random is
effectively what that looks like and so
if you keep doing what we're doing
that's what you can expect revolutions
and words to be commonplace really ugly
and and and you have politicians that
take the the bottom 50% and say it's not
your fault it's their fault and when
that divide becomes too much those
assets will get taken anyone's okay they
won't look like a so so the the rich in
that case are deluding themselves if it
can go on is there be pitchforks in the
street and and then now to move from
country to country that's it what the
existing system looks like if you would
loved inflation to happen if you just
said full stock and so one argument
that's a bad bad outcome right the other
argument is potentially just as bad an
outcome and that left if I let
capitalism work and stop propping up
banks everything else and let the system
fail and Rickon reset you would go
through a world global multi-year
depression right and and and there would
be a lot of unemployment there would be
a lot of problems in that so so because
the problem is now so big the solution
there are isn't I would love to say
there's a real easy solution and here's
what it is I can't say that right now
and nobody can and the people that are
saying that or deluding themselves right
they're not looking at for this from a
first principle standpoint or looking at
this second-order and third-order
consequences of the decisions but those
are the facts where we are and so I
guess in that environment so if you go
with the first one where there's the
Wars the revolutions etc it's not so
much one country verse another it's
basically the people versus the
establishment right but the problem is
it turns into look at the rise of
in the thirties right it was a friend it
was a fringe party that came into power
because there were bread lines in the
streets right and and that and that
happened because US called their debt
right and and they had to go into this
hyperinflation environment to get out of
the debt so they had to print money like
crazy to get over the debt and that
forced people in the street with no jobs
and they couldn't feed themselves and in
that environment people rise up and say
it's not your fault it sees people that
have the money it's their fault and when
you've done that and that's not a big
enough thing to retain power you have to
create a bigger enemy outside your
country so you're right the first order
consequence is rising up in the streets
right in inside country's second order
consequence is that's not a big enough
enemy to retain power and so you have to
it it's such a creek that it's really
predictable right we've seen it through
throughout history any time you get into
this this currency battles this is this
is what is likely outcome and it doesn't
need to look like that um but there
needs to be very critical debate on the
first principles on what's changed to be
able to avoid that to be able to avoid
bad outcome and I guess then if you go
to the second option which is let the
system fail right let the bad companies
get flushed out etc the is the argument
that they won't do that because of the
short-term pain that is there that's it
that's that's the argument the the the
short-term pain name a politician that
does the long-term good right they it's
it's really difficult to to to to place
a long-term bet against how much
short-term back pain so that's that's
actually what and I know you're a fan of
Bitcoin I am as well I hope I don't need
it right
I really hope I don't need it but but
all of the data is supporting that I'm
going to write because if I need it what
that means is currencies have failed
everywhere
and it becomes a new standard and we
have a harsh reset and it explodes in
value yes it creates a lot of wealth for
people that know that earlier that are
the tons of wealth but the reset is so
severe in the world that it also creates
staggering pain yeah and I guess as part
of that is Bitcoin the only answer or is
there something like gold right that's
just kind of more sound money or maybe
there's something else like what do you
think the potential solutions our
options are so so as a policy response
right now is oh and I'm involved in this
in Canada but but in the you saw the
same thing Tim Cook said with the policy
with the best policy response right now
would be where are the jobs in the
future gonna be if you if you're an
individual country or state or anything
else where are the jobs going to be and
and double down there instead of
propping up the existing system right
make a huge bet on where the jobs are
going to be in the future that bet is
technology right and so technology is
gonna accelerate from here and that is
where the jobs are going to be but it
won't create enough jobs to replace the
one that is there destroy that's kind of
the point so if you're playing game
theory in doing what you could do for an
in one economy double triple quadruple
their own technology because you built
it's a it's the new they used to build
roads right the roads are now technology
lanes right the the backbone of that our
world is a technology landscape and
that's where and that's where the
investment should be going for the
countries that do that they'll come out
stronger right but if every country does
that which likely it's pretty predictive
on sure countries did that and
everybody's competing for the same
scarce technology jobs and it's gonna it
but you're gonna have deflation anyways
like no matter what so from a so that's
would be the policy response that could
they could actually probably make at
least the money that you spent
then make a bigger difference to your
economy and and and then you wouldn't
naturally prop up prices that should
fall and it would it would transition so
you still have you're still with the
amount of debt in the world is about and
it mounted debt in any economy you're
gonna still have to reset that debt at
some point and and that that reset a lot
of people are gonna be wiped out all
right a lot of people that think that
can debt can be paid forever by
increasing more debts could more debt
more debt to those people are gonna be
wiped out